NARRATOR: On June 6, 1944,
stormed the beaches of Normandy.
23,400 more landed
from the skies.
It became known as
D-Day, the major turning
point of World War II.
But it almost never happened.
Why?
Well, try getting
three of the biggest
personalities in
history to agree
on something at the same time.
In September of 1939,
Britain officially
entered World War II.
In 1940, Winston Churchill
became Prime Minister, standing
alone against Nazi Germany.
Across the sea, Britain's
close ally, the United States,
remained neutral.
President Franklin
Delano Roosevelt
yearned to support his friend,
but for the American people,
it was a different story.
Traumatized by the Great
Depression and the horrors
of World War I, most
Americans favored
isolationism over intervention.
But they couldn't remain
isolated for long.
On December 7, 1941, Japan
attacked Pearl Harbor.
Neutrality was no
longer an option.
Less than 24 hours later,
Congress declared war on Japan.
By the end of the week, Germany
had declared war on the US.
From the beginning, US
President Franklin Roosevelt
and British Prime
Minister Winston
Churchill agreed on one thing--
an Allied victory would
require a massive invasion
of mainland Europe.
They just needed to get
their other ally, Russia's
leader Joseph Stalin, on board.
Back in the Soviet
Union, Stalin was
getting slammed, fighting the
Nazis in the eastern theater.
Attacking mainland
Europe and diverting
Nazi troops to the
west could ease
pressure on the Soviet army.
So Stalin was in.
But opening a front in the
West was easier said than done.
Internal pressures,
lack of resources,
and constantly
changing circumstances
pushed back the date
for a Western invasion.
And there was another problem--
Japan.
The US had its own
war in the Pacific
that required ships,
landing crafts, and troops.
They just couldn't provide
resources to launch
a successful attack in Europe.
Instead, Roosevelt's
advisors proposed
Operation Sledgehammer, a plan
to seize ports along France's
northwest coast and then
conduct a major invasion
in the spring of 1943.
Churchill's team countered
with Operation Torch.
The Americans would
invade Northwest
Africa, relieving British
forces defending the Suez Canal.
Churchill argued this
would improve relations
with the increasingly impatient
Soviets and lift Allied morale.
The Americans agreed.
A large scale attack on mainland
Europe would have to wait.
But it couldn't wait long.
Stalin was getting desperate.
If Churchill and
Roosevelt took too long
to offer military
relief for Russia,
Stalin might call for a
peace agreement with Hitler.
Roosevelt still couldn't
commit to a mainland invasion.
But in January of 1943,
he agreed to invade
the soft underbelly of Europe--
Sicily.
The Allies overran the
island, but once they crossed
into mainland Italy, they were
bogged down with high costs
draining resources.
The rough terrain with
fierce German resistance in
southern Italy eroded morale.
In November 1943, Roosevelt,
Churchill, and Stalin met.
They could no longer
wait to invade France.
The time was now.
Allied generals Dwight
Eisenhower and Bernard
Montgomery suggested a plan--
Operation Overlord.
A full-on invasion of Normandy.
Stalin saw it as the only way.
Churchill was skeptical.
He feared it would be a heavy
and hazardous adventure, paid
for with human life and blood.
But he agreed.
The plan was risky.
It hinged on cooperative weather
and the element of surprise.
If the Nazis caught
wind of their plan,
the Allies would undoubtedly
suffer a violent defeat.
Hitler knew an invasion
of France was coming.
It was only a matter of
when, where, and how many.
So the Allies set up
an elaborate campaign
of disseminating
misinformation in an effort
to trick the Nazis.
On June 6, 1944, Hitler
was caught off-guard.
132,600 American, British,
and Canadian forces
landed on five beaches along
the Normandy coast of France,
in the largest amphibious
military assault in history.
An additional
23,400 troops landed
inland by parachute or glider.
The fighting lasted
until September.
While the plan was an ultimate
success, Churchill was right.
On D-Day alone,
over 4,000 Allied
troops were confirmed
dead, and thousands
were wounded or missing.
The total casualties
for the invasion
included nearly
37,000 Allied dead.
Their efforts were not in vain.
By the end of September,
1944, all of northern France
was liberated.
Seven months later,
Allied forces would
finally defeat Nazi Germany.